[Music]
so i just finished watching spiderman no
way home spider-man no way home just got
out of our no way home showing we just
saw spider-man no way home
and i'm gonna go again tomorrow
man i don't even know what to say
honestly
i don't know
what did i just watch the movie was the
perfect combination between between
i don't know it's just perfect it was
just too much
i'm i literally was speechless i i left
infinity war crying and sobbing and i
was a mess and she had to hold me and i
was speechless she said she's never seen
me speechless like this after a marvel
movie all gotta come watch it
[Music]
i don't know what i was expecting i was
expecting it to be absolutely amazing
yeah it went above that which i just
wasn't expecting
[Music]
[Applause]
crazy movie highly recommended my mind
is blown right now how do we feel about
spider-man
yo so many emotions right now
this movie just delivers on so many
levels
i just i i enjoyed it so much it it's
more than a 10 out of 10 for me it's
it's definitely like even 20 out of 10
if i could rate it that absolutely
nothing you've ever seen before it has a
lot of intense moments in this movie and
um
oh my god man honestly i think it's the
best superhero superhero film
ever made i can't wait to watch it again
i'm so excited for what's next to come
it's
incredible amazing when peter
and peter
and peter
didn't don't know it's that by healing
the billions
they were also healing a million and
millions of people like us
yeah
it was a rough year
and it's ending very good
with this
fantastic movie
you